[Music]  I'm Eddie brought I'm the reporter now I  always seem to find myself questioning  something the government may not be  looking at I found something really bad  I have been taking  look around in the world who do you see  a planet from the brink of collapse  human games are disposable like man and  symbiote combined this is a new race  your species a higher life-form  what do you want me  [Applause]  we cannot get hurt people  we have a deal I believe so many flags  from the little time  to that power it's not completely awful  you have no idea how much you're scaring  me right now  Oh operator  and you just might survive guys you do  not want to do this trust me  we'll always come at a cost  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  oh I have a parasite yeah  neighbors chant  [Applause]  you